[Music]  we're pleased to reopen our community  outdoor spaces this includes our  playgrounds and dog parks we've given  all these areas are clean before opening  but we still encourage you to wash your  sterilize your hands after visiting  especially after using high touch areas  such as gates and playground equipment  please keep groups to a maximum of 10  people and try and keep a distance of 2  metres witness book to help keep you  safe we've also increased the frequency  of cleaning at our public toilets we  hope you enjoy our parks and reserves if  you need to contact us feel free to give  us a call through our center or through  our website